. This is really we're going to talk in the
next segment more about Matt Gates.
Donald Trump had to be talked out of publicly
defending Matt Gates.
Now, it's not stopping Matt Gates from claiming
he has Trump support.
And we're going to get to that later in the
show.
But there's a very interesting report from
CNN and Business Insider and a number of different
media outlets that Donald Trump had to be
talked out of publicly defending.
Republican Florida Congressman Matt Gates
as reports surfaced almost daily, something
new and very bad for Matt Gates, including
questions about whether Matt Gates had a sexual
relationship with a minor, whether he actually
trafficked that minor across state lines,
which would be very, very bad.
And Maggie Haberman from The New York Times
reported on CNN that Donald Trump wanted to
come out in defense of Matt Gates.
But presumably many of the people around Donald
Trump were saying, don't say a word.
These allegations are really serious.
Habermann said, quote, His first impulse was
he wanted to defend Gates.
You know, he's one of our people.
Several of his advisors told him it's a very
bad idea.
The nature of what Gates is being investigated
for is so serious that this is not something
that former President Trump should be out
on a limb for.
And then we've seen the silence from Trump
World and we now understand why.
Now, again, Matt Gates is still saying, I
have Trump support.
I've heard from Trump and it's all going great.
It's not clear whether that's true.
But we're going to talk about that after the
break.
The there are some within Donald Trump's circle
who actually celebrated the controversy.
Reportedly, there are some people around Trump
who really don't like Matt Gates and were
allegedly gleeful that Matt Gates was having
this problem.
Business Insider writes that another Trump
confidant echoed the Apsara echoed the assessment,
telling Politico, The reason you haven't seen
people in Magga defending Gates is less about
him being unpopular, which he is, and a lot
of circles, but more about the fact that he
hasn't done a single thing to make people
comfortable to defend him.
And case in point, every time Gates publicly
speaks about this scandal, it actually raises
new questions.
Gates seems to propose or introduce new potentially
derogatory information about himself every
single time that he does something publicly.
He spoke over the weekend at a very strange
event.
I'll have clips after the break for you.
It raises more questions about Gates, who
seems to be now making himself a martyr for
allegedly having paid a minor for sex.
Very, very strange when he did the Tucker
Carlson interview not last week, but the week
before.
He sort of strangely seemed to implicate Tucker
and even raised new questions denying that
he ever paid for sex, which at the time was
not even part of the publicly known investigation.
Just it gets worse every time, time after
time after time.
So for now, you know, one of the really funny
things is in some way, doesn't this invalidate
the Q and on conspiracy?
Because Kuhnen is a conspiracy theory based
on the idea that Donald Trump was sent to
fight an imaginary child sex trafficking ring
run run by Democrats.
If Trump was eager to defend Gates despite
child sex trafficking claims, it doesn't really
sound like the type of guy who would be fighting
against child sex trafficking that Kuhnen
believes him to be.
Just a side note about yet another one of
these conflicts between these various conspiracy
theories.
But despite Trump not publicly supporting
Matt Gates, Matt Gates is saying that he still
has Donald Trump's support.
So we're going to talk about that after the
break.
Make sure that you are following me on Instagram.
You can find me on Instagram at David Pakman